[Music]
working for the man every night and day
I was worrying about the way things
might have been
big will keep on turning turn ing Proud
Mary keep on burning burning rolling
rolling rolling rolling rolling rolling
on the hay babe shout out uh R.I.P uh
Tina Turner we just got the news today
that she died I know this might be come
out two weeks from now but we just got
the news and we're two weeks sorry I
butchered the Lyrica it happened it had
she doesn't you know she's passed on now
so she might be looking down what do you
think happens to you when you die oh
it's not even let's not even go there
because you know what when we're not
recording that's all I think about right
you know what I mean I just want to say
real quick before you give your answer
that the only time I feel like I'm ever
in heaven when I'm alive is when I'm
having a Dietz and Watson hot dog go
ahead very nice yeah very nice I talked
to someone this weekend we were on the
road in Texas and I was with veter oh
yeah Texas where they say everything's
bigger yes yeah we had good shows down
you ever have sexist in Texas
uh
yes oh there you go
nice yes I have I remember it now great
um they uh what was I saying we were
with veter on the road oh Texas okay I
just Shout Out Gary Vader looks like a
baby Shout Out Gary veter uh look him up
he's the best
yes yeah he's with me on the road
um so uh I don't understand I don't want
to get into it but I don't understand
how anything started not even the Big
Bang okay like it doesn't make any sense
how does anything
anything as far back and as far out as
you want to go exist
what made
matter what was there
before it well I know that this sounds
like a high College bongs talk and I
know it might be trite and I know it
might be like people talk about all the
time but I still will never be able to
wrap my head around it and I don't think
anyone can give me an answer I don't
think number one I don't think that
some of those answers are even designed
for our brain to compute be able to
comprehend what I will say is even have
a piece of the puzzle even blow your
balls off even more is there is a lot of
theories out there now that not only
is you know the the our universe and all
that and and all the universe that have
ever existed
that we have gotten to this point before
and that we this might be the eighth or
some people believe the ninth existence
of us
throughout however long time has been so
we think our universe started four
billion years ago and maybe or whatever
the number is and maybe it has but
that's this that's the eighth existence
there have been things that have
happened all the way do you recall why
they specifically said eight or like
here's what they I why I don't know why
they said eight or nine I've I've I have
um that I I don't know I was uh spotting
a guy at the gym and he was talking to
me about this I he so and and but but uh
press bench press bench press how many
how many reps was a strong guy he did
about he did about 10 at at 270. when
you put your hand on that do you ever
lift more than you let on to give them a
little confidence I try to be honest
with them but sometimes I could you know
he was he was a rageful man clearly on
steroids yelling at me about when the
universe began so I want to just tell
him I didn't barely touch it I'm just
guiding you but by the way when you're
bet when you're spotting a guy at the
bench press there's no way to not teabag
him yeah you're always teabagging him
yeah and you just have to accept that or
at least it's too close for comfort your
testes and his forehead your ball calls
are the closest to another man's
forehead they might ever be unless
you're a gay man right so or you're
experimenting on the weekends it is
Fleet Week so or it was two weeks ago so
so um but what they're saying what what
what what the science is is if right now
I pressed a button and I could press a
button called nuclear warhead press a
button and I extinguish life everything
is gone everything every single human
being that could possibly clean up
anything is living living matter is Off
the Earth living living things are gone
if I press the button everything but
okay so we're like it's like a perennial
plant though we're gonna we're gonna
Sprout back no here's the thing
everything with the heartbeat is gone
and buildings the only things that are
up are buildings and concrete structures
in 10 000 years of untouched nothing's
being touched in 10 000 years you would
have 75 of all human civilization that
ever existed buried under I think it's
five feet of sediment within a hundred
thousand years you would have 100 of all
human civilization any any trace of us
buried in over 50 feet of sediment and
not only that the Earth pushes it down
like a like a garbage disposal and then
it gets burned in the core of the earth
so people feels like an incinerator when
people say oh yeah but wouldn't there be
some evidence of this other
civilizations from the from this fifth
time that we've done this the answer is
no the scientists say no there is there
isn't it wouldn't be it would the Earth
would take it back and burn it and then
start life again where did you read this
Theory
that was talking about my daughter's
birthday party
like Delilah I caught a conversation
she's having with uh Jimmy from next
door yeah yeah um yeah Delilah she was
like it's time for the cake I was like
well we've done this before
um wow yeah but but I don't know if it's
true but can you tell me like the big
bang as well like a couple of show on
CBS a couple of particles that don't
agree with each other hit and made an
explosion exactly and matter when
everywhere and then that matter
progressed yes I don't nah I don't
believe I feel I don't believe that I
think how did the thing that banged each
other how'd they get there right that's
the thing the chicken or the egg nobody
knows not even but but it will never
know we'll never know never it just
really chaps my ass that
we are but a fleeting
the Earth is a cell right I just chapped
my ass that we won't have the answers I
do wonder I do Wonder
if we will ever have the answers as a
civilization no and when would that be
it's but think about it though no right
because we're going to turn over and
turn over and turn it's going to be a a
rediscovery like my thing is like look
does anyone does anyone
no
the full story in the in out anywhere I
believe that there have to be people and
a lot of people call these they're
reptilian people the top one percent the
maybe the top levels of the government
there have to be people though on this
planet I don't know if they know the
full answer but have to know a lot more
information than us as the general
public would know there have to be
people the only reason for keeping back
information of that nature is that if it
is sensitive or can if it got out it
would cause you know
so you're saying then that
in saying that you're saying that you do
believe that there are probably a good
amount of things that if we knew right
now would cause Mass hysteria and we
just we just fly blind well look at it
look at it because sometimes I'm like oh
that wouldn't be true but look at it on
just a small scale there have been
things that I could not tell the adult
members of my own family because if I
told them
they would it would cause a problem so
think about that on a small scale how we
do that now think about it in charge of
people of governments and countries and
you have information you cannot tell all
these people what you know right you
cannot that was a very uh that's a very
good make it a micro situation that's
what it is kind of conceptualize it but
make things there's no um there is no
obligation to humanity
to reveal this like who gets at what
level are people who is the person being
like we're gonna keep this one to us the
Jews okay
all of them so all the Jews know
everything they know it all you just
gotta find your local Jew friend Jewish
Jewish neighborhood shaffir he'll tell
you yeah already tells me at times Ari
will tell me the secrets
does it
bother you or you're nah you're good
you're pretty good pretty good it might
bother me
know that we don't know and we don't
know what possibly
Insidious things Loom and that we will
also pass and not ever know what this
was or why and how it ends or if it does
end or if it does have a beginning does
that not bother you and I think that
it's more prevalent in my thoughts now
because of my age you know there's a
little bit of sense of more mortality
right now right like your mind never
goes there when your grandparents are
alive even your parents are young sure
you feel Invincible right but then when
you start to feel a little older or see
people in your family age and things
like that you start to have different
perspectives that becomes real yeah
right right on right so I think I'm
thinking existentially a lot lately
right I've brought up plenty of time
which is good what but it but it does
alarm me and give me anxiety I think
like this like for me again we talk you
know the universe things change is what
we live in a place where I don't know
why but all the the world that we live
in the universe that we're in right now
is change it's always change right
nothing lasts forever
it's like it's almost elasticity it's
and and it's it's saturated SATs it's
all that yeah you you I think like
here's an example like there's monks I
forgot what country they're from I'm
gonna go Tibet when you hear among it's
like it's thermal in place when you say
my when you say monks you think it's all
you ever hear is Tibetan Monks like all
your is like a Tijuana crack corn it's a
One-Stop shop for monks crack [__] are
from Tijuana for all your monkeys you go
to Tibetan
so that's that's what it is
so I think it's a Tibetan Monks what
they do is they spend days four five six
sometimes even seven days building sand
castles yes that but also building
sandcastles like a big competition no
what they do is they build sand castles
by the beach yes kind of like
competition they build sand castles by
the beach and then the monk did that
oh and then add [__] they'll be sick
that's sick already and then as soon as
they're done as soon as they're done
with a sculpture like this they let the
ocean wash it away or they knock it down
themselves because they are living they
practice living in the ever-changing
flow of life so when people get mad that
you know they just clean their kitchen
and now their the dishes are in their
sink again or they just clean the house
and the kids mess it up but they just
did the laundry now there's more laundry
in the hamper you have to release
yourself from getting upset and angry at
those things because it's life has
changed it's the Everlasting change so
we're gonna change they're surfing the
top of that wave yes our bodies Our
energy is going to change into something
else and that is going to happen yes yes
so that's why I believe so that helps me
kind of release my thoughts of if I
don't know everything that's okay I'm
just going to try to learn as much
that's why I go to different restaurants
on Staten Island do you believe
do you do you believe it or are you
choosing to believe it I believe it now
actually I would love to believe it yeah
because it helps yeah I don't know man
but you can't tell me like maybe I'm a
little green here obviously I didn't
really read up on the green but um I
feel it you look actually look tan not
as tan as vanitya but you look tan you
do look tan where you've been
I will do it that'll do it Spain will do
it yeah
I do you know exactly what the bit like
because because the the biggest Theory
we have right now that is that is
publicly uh accepted and and I you know
unless unless you're a creationist is
The Big Bang Theory right I think it's a
number that's a big prevalent scientific
that's what Neil deGrasse Tyson says and
that's who I go by right uh
okay uh can you do you remember like
offhand what that is uh you know there's
a Big Bang Theory particles that yeah
exploded exploded caused our you know
resulted in our universe the planets
everything that's inconceivably it
exploded in a in in in a
in a size that we can't even conceive
nukes on nukes on like nuclear
explosions like like like whoa okay so
the things that exploded how'd they get
there that's the question that nobody
has the answer to they can go back to as
far as that point
so that's but that's the thing that I've
just released myself from because again
we'll never know that's also just our
best theory in modern times it means
jack ship right like uh a thousand years
like 500 years ago whatever I don't know
when this Theory came out the Big Bang
but before that there was another theory
Sure or multiple theories and there will
be more theories well we've talked about
this I think on on this show before is
like the smartest person in you know the
1800s thought that dinosaurs were still
real like and we know now dinosaurs were
still alive right back then because they
couldn't travel they could they were
living in their own village now that we
can travel and see you know the planet
from like a bird's eye view we know more
things but there's things right now that
we think are true that will look like
idiots for believing 200 years from now
I wonder what those are so you just have
to accept see I I I have a problem with
this though right because where is our
place here then it's just really really
tough well but that but that's what I
focus inward I uh my family and friends
so I try to be in the moment love life
enjoy the little things oh that's so
great so that's but that's what I try to
do now as much as I can is is rather
than trying to spend time and energy
thinking about what came before the Big
Bang I say I rather than say how can I
be more present with my kids how can I
you know get the job done you know how
can I you know uh do something each day
that's going to be impactful for me or
how can I help somebody else I try to
just put my thoughts there and then even
then I run out of ideas but I'm like let
me keep it all small I don't let my mind
like I don't care about being the
greatest of all time that I've ever
lived that means nothing to me because I
can be the greatest of all time that
I've ever lived to to it's subjective I
could be the greatest to somebody so
it's like because your opinion of uh you
know whatever we're comedians so say
like our community is like don't you
want to be the next Chappelle it's like
no he should have my sensibility right I
don't care yeah you know I also know
people that don't eat like Chappelle so
it's like you can't be the greatest to
everybody all the time sure sure so so
it's like so I'm like let me keep it
small so for me I try to get the
knowledge like I listen to these great
thinkers like a Neil deGrasse Tyson or
you listen to you know what Elon Musk
has to say about things and Tesla go
back and all their science and you know
even even you know uh uh you know even
science like our Science Now is the way
it was but the ancient science was more
like mystical it was all like there was
and and now those are the like the Elon
Musk of Shadows
Shadows
mystical is cool but we can't shout out
exhibit He's the bad one right no
exhibit's great exhibits great mystical
is the one who's in trouble he had some
dust ups with them mysticals no bueno
yeah I think exhibits great time maybe
no but I think he's going back mystical
oh I think that's so cool
who said they're gonna [__] on a
toothbrush in a rap song was that
mystical great lyric
um but but what I think about the
mysticism Shake yes watch yourself right
yeah that's him that's mystical right I
can't even move my dick in my head yeah
we should do that
so I think about I think about that
about like you know even science even
our type of science babe do you wanna
oh boy oh boy
oh
are you prepared for it
I'm gonna tell you I'm just gonna start
it out with this with this with the
headline okay and I'm gonna tell you
yeah
John D Rockefeller yeah created the
public school education system for evil
not for good ah where did you read this
why is that I watched the video I
watched the video okay our evil our
education system that our public
education system is designed it is
designed in this country to keep limit
to keep mediocracy
is that did I say that right MIDI
mediocracy mediocracy mediocracy
meritocracy meritocracy I don't mean I
mean
colonoscopy or colonoscopy yeah
um being mediocre yeah beating being me
serious because what happened was is we
had no public education system we had
nothing divided by grades and diplomas
we had none of that before John D rock
where we had diplomas in college but
public education was not a thing
everybody would go to school in one room
you would just learn you know very
mundane basic things but this
publication Johnny D rocks came in and
did what JDR came in and said what I
need is workers for my oil field I need
workers to I have I'm making so much
money so what we need to do is create a
system to make people think that there
can get ahead in life and they could be
me one day of course they can't so what
we'll do is we will attack the youth we
know that the older people who are set
in their ways are never going to conform
and never going to go work in the oil
field for minimum wage I never it was
actually from Prussia it was oppression
it was depression the Germans uh you
know Germany used to be called Prussia
the Prussian school system is what we've
adopted as our as our franco-prussian
war Franco pressure more as our school
system now and what it's designed to do
is to create obedient workers who get
from the time they're in kindergarten
learn how to follow the rules and stay
in line and celebrate being mediocre JJ
the fellow did that John D rockefell did
that so he could keep his Monopoly in
his Oil Business see it though I don't
see it so there's a great video by
j-tran so mass mass
education systems and infrastructure in
place right for him to be basically
creating an army of drones yes that will
be
yes have a mindset to fall online and I
mean right
yeah the Board of Education I think it's
the Board of Education right pimp this
is I I just heard of this I've used
Viator all the time when I watched this
two days ago I looked at Viator let's
I use Viator oh I know what it is are
sponsoring our show no I love this place
is this is that the experience website
where you could book like a helicopter
flight every time I go travel I go to
the first app I go to is the Viator app
or viator.com and I look at how what
experiences I can have in that city or
country via Taurus 300 000 bookable
travel experiences in a hundred and over
190 countries via seriously I'm telling
you I use Viator I get the best deals on
tours when I went to London when I went
to Italy I have I have Scotland I have
viatory like I can look back so you were
you were I'm a big fire truck I've been
using them since 2015 you're an OG I
love Fire tour yeah I found out about
them two days ago I went on the website
and it's pretty damn cool you put the
city you're going to be in and it just
lists all the things you could do there
if you're and sometimes I use it in New
York too my home City Home City they'll
find you can go on tours you don't even
know existed download the Viator app now
and use the code viator10 for 10 off
your first booking one app over 300 000
experiences you'll remember member do
more with Viator I'm telling you I can
advocate for this app from a genuine
Place more than maybe any other product
we've ever talked about on the show I've
used it maybe a hundred times Viator and
you can I'm going to use my own discount
Viator app now download it use the code
Viator
v-i-a-t-o-r-10 for 10 off your first
booking always flexible support the
sport free uh uh cancellation payment
options 24 7 service all true value
towards the best check it out that's
viatora one zero
here we go as always this podcast
sponsored by better help that's right we
love it and here's the thing guys
therapy is about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
look
we don't know what we want I don't know
what the hell I want we don't know why
we react to things that we do until you
actually talk things out it's about
processing and I benefit from therapy
and I benefit from a better help and if
you've never done it this is the perfect
way to try it mental health and being
aware of your mental health is very very
important what I like about better help
is you can do it from the comfort of
your own home don't have to go to an
office it's all done online entirely
online it's convenient flexible suited
to your schedule all you do is fill out
this brief questionnaire they match you
with the licensed therapist you can
switch therapists anytime for no
additional cost they really make it
simple and right now all you have to do
is go to better help that's help
betterhelp.com hey babe to get 10 off
your first month
that's betterhelp help.com hey babe
discover your potential with better help
gonna get 10 off your first month
wow he had ulterior motives you're
saying for evil but he he suspected that
he plays a long game and after he
instituted these institutions that
he would eventually begin
skimming the crop of kids for him well
he took it from like when Prussia
invaded Poland I want to say it was the
1800s say it they knew I'm gonna say it
they knew the prussians knew that they
now invaded Poland they took over Poland
they were not going to get a Polish guy
in his 40s or 50s to all of a sudden and
be like we love Prussia not going to
happen so they said no pressure they
said do what you want to do
yes eat your kawamkis you know have fun
with kabasi as long as they're from
Dietz and Watson do whatever you want to
do he said what instead what they'll do
is depressions is get to this children
get the children in school make it
palatable to the parents say I want they
they started putting up schools and
saying come teach your kids we're going
to teach your kids how to be better
workers we're going to teach your kids
we're going to give them education we're
going to give them a chance to live the
life that you couldn't because you're
stuck here on a farm but that also has
come to fruition through education but
so as I'm saying well his motives he
didn't think that while doing that he
was also just educate they'll be saying
with public school very very very very
very very few public school graduates
get to like you know CEOs of companies
and like there are certainly a lot of
them that do but the percentage is
smaller as opposed to even private
schooling sometimes sometimes the public
school education well I'm saying how is
the the concept is the same in public
and private school
so private school co-opted
public school but then
for the positive reasons for example in
public school yeah in most public
schools yeah do not teach a course in
finance that's on purpose because they
do not want you to know John D
Rockefellers of the world do not want
you to know how to do that that
basically is carried over to today the
curriculum is not changing the general
education board that that governs John D
Rockefeller and his friend made that up
that what they just they just there's no
board I mean it's french is doing
everything they just wrote it they said
this sounds this sounds this sounds uh
like you know pretty authoritarian this
is this is an authority right here this
public education board it's a great
Google education is evil and I watched
it and it was pretty well how is it how
is it um you know Global then
like was he trying to do it what did it
Sprout the public schooling Sprout up
locally
before it ended up being like
federalized
that I don't know but what I do know is
that this education system here is
designed the public education system is
designed to keep you in line and it's
designed for you to follow common
knowledge well it I mean it like even
even like because that's salacious even
this like you like like you and I right
we have a a privilege not because we're
white but it is there but mostly it's
privilege because we get to do in our
careers in entertainment we don't have
to stick to a schedule we don't have to
stick to what time is really irrelevant
to us it doesn't matter what the time of
the day is we're kind of doing a career
that we want to do the John D
Rockefellers and the powers that be do
not they're allow some of it we are very
blessed you have to count our blessings
we are very blessed to be able to do
this even if we can only do it for a few
more years we're doing it now because
these people do not want you to do that
what they want you to do is be stuck in
the nine to five always you always need
to be a gerbil on the wheel because
those are the best most obedient workers
you will borrow money from them to get
house
that you can't afford the interest rates
all these things that's pretty to keep
in line what what is the point of what
why does my five-year-old have to be in
school at 8 A.M there's no reason to for
me to wake up my child at 6 30 in the
morning to get her ready to be in school
at 8am oh the reason is to make her an
obedient worker and have her start
listening to the rules now
yeah but also it's a function of
how we structure our day but it's not
going to send you well where does that
come school at night but where does that
come from why can't our day start at 10
A.M why does it have to start at the
crack of dawn you have to struggle as a
parent to wake your children up and have
them set an alarm we're saying that yes
but the structure of our day but goes
back to the big bang when did it start
why does it start this way what's the
point why can't we work 10-6 why can't
we get the seven knowing that most
humans don't get to bed till 11 or 12
why can't we work from 10 to 6 and that
would make everything more functional
because they don't want that because
then you'll start to be more rested
you'll start to think more freely no
you'll start to think more freely the
reason they want you to Crazy hired
irritable so you stay in line you get
the money from them you do you you
celebrate you celebrate your degree
which me in the grand scheme of things
means nothing and you're celebrating
being mediocre that's what John D
Rockefeller was that's right does he
have uh his his um
hey babe exactly
I was born in this country I'm like some
presidents
let's see his Sports yeah
um does John D Rockefeller his his
public perception at large is it a
positive one uh I think it's slowly
becoming more negative I think like
anything else like every other character
in the Vanderbilts also
do some [__]
Vandy he's a big Vanderbilt guy uh who
is Rockefeller it's Vanderbilt was way
more uh was made way more um yeah I
don't know who was a bigger dick wealthy
than than Rockefeller right
I mean Rockefeller and Vanderbilt are
are the two memes or the two
Rockefellers for a reference to what is
this guy Rockefeller right right yeah or
Vanderbilt yes yeah
is Rockefeller the richest person of all
time ever
adjusted for inflation
yeah so Bill Gates but is it even not
even the most rich man right now Bill
Gates no I think it's like isn't it the
Mexican guy Carlos Slim someone just was
it was it a prince someone thinks Elon
Musk and then there's like three below
it right well so wow I didn't know
Bernard Arnold 202 Bill schmillion
billion dollars 202 schmillis now who's
also what's his business
oh CEO of the luxury fashion company
lvmh what then Elon Musk Bezos bill yeah
see that see like that's the thing like
you hear that like we don't even know
what those companies are it's like what
is it they probably just own all the fat
they probably own everything from the
Gap to Old Navy to all the fashionistas
there was
there was a day there was a day where
that man had was
poor or regular oh yeah unless he was
born into enormous wealth yeah
well that's in the rich keep getting
richer right that's a real thing because
they keep the wealth at the top like you
can't even get into the BET like like
the art industry is that has by far the
best return of any type of investment
you could possibly do the problem is is
to get those types of Investments you
need like a hundred million dollars
worth of art right so they do that on
purpose that's why you're not gonna
probably become an art dealer get into
the art industry by going through a
public Edge by going through any school
system a lot of these people they do
things that they're just they're playing
by other rules don't you feel like the
art industry is
complete complete complete complete
[__] that's why I put my money in
nfts
[Laughter]
that's even worse like it's it is just
kind of crazy it is and and it and it's
and it's completely 100
communicated fabricated it regulates
itself the people are controlling it
it's all yeah it has nothing to do with
like you know at least the market is
like yes people are controlling it but
it's something bigger it's currency it's
values of their country art is like
literally one a couple of guys being
like this costs this much because I said
something yeah it's like the auction
houses and even the influences like the
dealers that like they will like tell
you what is I mean obviously
historically if you're getting a work
that's limited or from a famous thing
that's gonna you know mean something to
a lot of people in general not just the
art community right like it has value
but like the stuff now contemporary
artists are like breaking out and I'm
guilty of it I have a couple I have a
couple of days and pieces in my house
yeah I like I like the art in your house
though thanks I was told that the one
that I paid for has doubled in price
there you go they're blue chip they're
called Blue Chip artists you know yeah
but I honestly who do I sell that to
somebody wants to who do I sell to sell
it to one of the Jonas Brothers Maybe
in touch with them that's what I would
do AI generated photo of fake Pentagon
explosions
wait a minute like
stock market oh okay
oh that's why my that's why my accounts
were down today
dude I'll tell you nothing you want to
just talk about anxiety about things
there might be a full-on default by the
U.S but I mean we might default
on our debt that the United States of
America and that might happen this
coming week so I got cash in my walls
baby yeah but how much cash do you have
in your walls because 100
000. I got about 100
yeah no no I I don't think that's gonna
happen I mean it could happen but if
again if it happens what are we going to
do we're going to lose a lot of [__]
money that is an investment well hello
fresh better pay the [__] up
yeah dude I am nervous I have a call set
with my financial advisor tomorrow
because like I want to know if I
shouldn't be moving money around but
where can you get more money though into
crypto what are you gonna move it no
just well yeah bonds aren't even sure
anymore what is he saying he's saying
that he hasn't said anything I got to
get him on the phone you're saying that
this like the stock market is gonna like
you're saying that the US government is
going to default on the like treasury
bonds and stuff that people have yes
yeah and that is going to cause
everything to fall apart at the seams
because a treasury bond is an
interesting thing do you know what like
a t-bill is I kind of do and don't I
forget you know it's pretty finance
major it's like no but a TiVo is pretty
sick because it is basically what it is
is you're the government is just
basically you're loaning you're loaning
your money to the governor correct isn't
that [__] crazy that's what
everything is that's what banking is
yeah it's like you're just loaning it to
the government and the government's just
paying you back with interest yeah it's
like you're alone shocking your own
government so you're saying they'll
default on that
yeah there is I mean they're like I'm
not because they could at any time like
I'm not going to pay back I'm like give
me my money and then they're just like
nobody it ends up it ends up devaluing
the the dollar sure we have two we can't
print more like it's it's it's a it's
but that's why they're gonna but here's
here's because then they're gonna that's
when they're gonna start
you know pedaling out the digital
currency and they're going to start
pedaling out digital currency digital
fingerprints digitizing everything and
that's the slippery slope that's where
we all get [__] and we are under the
control John D Rockefeller is probably
still alive he's probably still alive
calling the shots but probably all
involved in his game still working for
his oil fields we don't even realize if
he's watching and we know that you are
uh email us at
no pressure Network gmail.com and let us
know if you want to come on let us know
what your real intentions were with the
public schooling system and have they
changed yeah and let us know if you're
still alive What secrets you know and
also what do you want for a coffee
breakfast we're having a tea go pick
that up yeah and by the way thanks to
the Rockefeller Center we love Rockville
Center got an audition for SNL but we do
appreciate it maybe you're not have you
not never have you even gotten we've
talked about this we've had to I've
never auditioned I was told I was asked
if I wanted to audition and you never
did it end up I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna audition for that goddamn show
you'd be terrific and if I if I can't do
it the 1975 to help me I'm gonna start
messaging them again
um so we got incoming messages from
Rockefeller 1975. now
by the way I want to ask you quick I
haven't what'd you eat for breakfast
today myself yeah I had do it yourself
yeah I tell you what I had I had a uh
these Trader Joe's they sell these egg
like pre-made egg white things oh that
you just put in the microwave for one
minute egg white spinach and what have
you it's like 130 calories really good
okay and I had a believe it or not I had
a uh athletic greens well I like
athletic Rings yeah they don't break
your fast by the way they don't they
don't I asked you this though right
athletic greens are 25 calories I put a
shot of apple cider vinegar shout out
your father yeah in athletic greens and
I have that and I have that okay yeah
because because actually when I lose
weight a lot of it is because like my
first thing I have is athletic greens
and then I'm satiated until like
mid-afternoon they don't they do not
break your fast okay so you can if you
can continue to do that you do a little
you little thin do you feel thin are you
down I'm down but I got work right I get
a lot of work
but I'm in it I'm in it you're in it and
you're ready to win it a minute
um now
what
oh oh yes can we talk about this ozempic
I think ozempic now came out as the
miracle drug but it's got it's starting
to become problematic those epic curbing
appetite curbing appetite and a lot of
people are losing weight but I heard
it's blowing holes in people's colons
and people are [__] themselves left
and right and it's actually causing like
ulcers and I think if you're not a
diabetic you shouldn't just be like like
girls are like going to give a
trendiness girls are like doing those
epic a week before Coachella you know
what I mean you can't do that oh and
then they're just gonna blow up the
Porta Johnson get can't well that and
then I think I think it actually has
like you can like get like organ shut
down oh okay I was gonna ask you as a
side effect that you [__] or is this
something bad happening inside I think
both right
club right I mean good club that that
it's probably gonna plummet right I mean
like you can't this yeah yeah but I
think that it is here's the thing there
is no miracle drug you're gonna have to
it just it takes a long time you gotta
change your Habit to change your way
Paul said it you gotta you better work
that's all you can do yeah I just
watched uh the article architectural
digest Open Door episode of RuPaul's
home RuPaul's home yeah you really did
it you really watched it I don't believe
you I watched it last night give me
Cliff Notes right now without thinking
about it whatever tell me three things
you learned about it golf sure the day
it came out it was out for three days
and it had 2.5 million views already
um it's it's it's it's it's it's not my
style it is over the top and excessive
but
it's very of him he has a closet for
men's clothes and a closet for women's
clothes and those are both full rooms
and it's more clothes than I've ever
seen it's like a department store in his
in his home yeah
um
what else can I tell you about this
um wait this is his disco ballroom with
26 disco balls on the ceiling that they
throw parties at uh so RuPaul has made a
lot of money RuPaul I mean this look
that's his home it looks like a jewelry
store it's it's it's it's it's it's
crazy dude do you want to go to RuPaul's
House
I'll tell you another thing I want to go
we know people that know RuPaul no we
can get to Rupaul I would love to get to
Rupaul RuPaul was on top of the list to
have guests on uh Joker's last season
didn't want to do it I don't think we I
don't know if we reached out to I don't
know if we got in touch but he was also
an excellent host I watched every
episode of this ever I'm a big fan and
he was very good at clean concise and
entertaining and informative and he kept
it light one thing though is at at the
end of every room he cracked himself up
this is one thing I noticed he'd be like
well that's what you got to do if you
want to do it anyway
and then it would cut and you go to the
next room and then he ended it that way
again from the next room you gotta love
that everything was
you gotta make yourself laugh
I like RuPaul do you think we can get
RuPaul on the show
I don't know if RuPaul is going to come
to this office
you don't think so if we took our
equipment to RuPaul's yeah well now
you're cooking with butter now right I
think more people though who seem
unattainable are more attainable than
you think than we all think I think that
there's a lot of times where it's
actually the the people seem the most
unattainable might be actually
attainable sure I get that because
they're so insulin comfortable they're
so insulated and they're like you know
what I'm willing to try something new
because I've I've won at so many things
in life let's give these people a shot I
will say as I watch so go DM and go
stand outside your favorite uh you know
uh celebrity Hollywood people's homes
and see see if they'll talk to you
because some might
don't come to ours uh no um I watched
RuPaul and I realized I was watching him
that I don't even see him as a man or a
woman he's very angry he's a he's a
RuPaul he's very androgynous yeah
because I felt while I was watching him
I still I I literally didn't feel
a male or female from him he's like his
own thing he is he is his own but it is
crazy because he you do see him now
equally in both
in both you know you see him as in Drag
and you see him as himself a lot it's
not like in the beginning I never saw
him as a man until he started coming out
in suits with you know his bald and all
that stuff right but he he it is it is
fascinating to me that
when he disrobes he's just walking
around with a swinging penis in his
house yeah because I don't not that he's
a woman I don't see him as a man or a
woman but like if anything you think of
RuPaul and you think of in Dragon I
don't know it just I he's so androgynous
that it it it's it's amusing to me to
picture him walking around the house
naked [__] marry kill RuPaul Logan Paul
Paulie Shore
RuPaul Logan Paul Paulie Shore [__]
America
I marry RuPaul because you get the house
you get the fashion yeah you get real
you get I mean he is Pleasant he's
successful he's clean he has a wonderful
house he seems loyal he seems loyal
seems loyal also he's hot when he puts
on the The Outfits 100
um I would probably
what's up everybody listen I got a brand
new hour of standard material and I'm
shooting a comedy special in Atlanta in
December I don't have the exact dates
yet but just know in Atlanta December
I'm coming to you and I am putting on a
slew of cities from September to
December so see tell me if you don't see
your city there hit me up on at Christy
comedy on social media and tell me if
you want me to come to your city but
they're here September 23rd right now
has tickets left the theater at Madison
Square Garden New York City Radio City
September 22nd is sold out so go get
your tickets at chrisdcomedy.com for my
fall tour in Atlanta I'm coming to you
to do my species I love it too I am
filming my special at the Vic in Chicago
on December 1st and 2nd and thus I am
also kicking off a tour I will be all
over the place Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Ohio Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Wilmington Delaware Torrington
Connecticut uh Macon Georgia
Savannah Georgia Athens Georgia Peoria
Rockford Springfield Olen Illinois
Duluth Appleton Rochester Minnesota uh
I'm gonna be all over I'm gonna be uh
like I said in Hartford and I'm going to
be in Syracuse doing some clubs and some
theaters that'll all be announced very
very soon but if you want to see me
right away you just see me on tour with
the guys
impracticaljokerslive.com uh this
weekend coming up we're on Columbus
Cleveland Detroit then Minneapolis Des
Moines Kansas City and then we close out
in Nashville Indianapolis and St Louis
all those tickets are on sale right now
at impracticaljokerslive.com
sex with uh Logan Paul okay he's in his
prime for sex yes and he's and he has
his drink Prime yeah right and not that
I want to have sex with him but you're
telling me I have to yeah I have a gun
to you literally make it good and I
think that he is he exercises you know
he's young he probably has a Vigor and a
big ball bag up a little bit yeah
whatever nice he's receptive to that
stuff and then you know at least sure
unfortunately and he's had his time
that's yes yeah Paul only Shore as as an
ex-girlfriend of mine from Ireland her
Irish mother would always say oh you've
had her day
as if to say like just it's not about
you've had your day that's what you're
saying you've had your day yeah I was 19
years old she was already telling me yo
you've had your day I was like oh all
right I'm a young child yeah I thought
like I was I'm actually just looking for
more days but speak in other sentences
uh say other sentences with that accent
Jesus Mary and Saint Peter
would you like Porter
would you like Porter this island they
say butcher Island would you like would
you like a a bit of butter
oh well you've had your day okay which
um now you never practice that you just
know it because we've heard those things
over so when you go to speak you're like
oh it's a potato famine yes it's a
potato right potato now what is John
you're from America are you do you does
it not blow your balls clean off every
time you learn about an English actor
that is speaking in American you know
they're all British from succession yeah
they're all pretty much about to bring
up I think they're Aussie and British
and you would never know it there's no
sign of it it's not like oh they [__]
that word up well that sentence up how
even though they get dialect coaches how
do you think that you can you can master
that Irish accent which I believe is a
little over the top in one way but at
the authentic Irish accent with a
dialect coach to the point that you
could star in a movie and people could
watch that and be like oh he's not
American
he's he's I mean sorry he's American
he's not really Irish like how did they
get every English actor does it everyone
I've never ever seen
and I can appreciate the flexing of the
pectorals I wanted to do it I've never
ever seen I've never caught someone and
be like nah that person's not really
American
English people are born with an ability
that we don't have and also Daniel
Day-Lewis is British yeah that I knew
what but can I say something else why is
it unless I'm
misinformed that Americans
aren't getting British roles and having
to do a British accent because I think
that they're just better at it I think
that they truly are just look at Mark
rylance's hair I don't know who that is
you know who he is
his hair is wild he hasn't figured in
about every film I ever made okay yeah
yeah
it is one of those things do they do it
I I honestly truthfully don't know at
all they but I I think about it even
when they sing they never sound very
accent it's it's one of those things
that it is it is as big of a mystery as
the Big Bang nobody knows there's nobody
that has a real answer for it okay okay
so
there's nothing that shiv
I think shiv has got to be American
she's not mom's games Tom wamscams is
not nice ship can you Google what kind
what country is shiv from succession
from snook I believe her name is I think
she's Australian I think
and then what about uh [__]
right there from uh
terrorism show with the red hair Kiefer
Sutherland no no the guy right there he
just had up there I I was my balls left
when when I found out about him too
where's Sarah snook from
Sarah Snook
girls
Australian she's an Australian actress I
love her I love shiv she's got a very
very original what tell me right now
what how does it end tell me
the succession finale what's your
prediction this might this will probably
come out a week after the show but
what's your prediction how's it going to
end you go first and I'll do me okay so
I really don't I lean one way but I
really believe it could be either way
now I think if you watched last episode
I'm caught up okay and this is gonna be
out later so this doesn't come out for
two weeks oh well all right if you don't
wanna know don't don't watch
um
the way they're setting it up right is
we're left to see if the deal happened
the big deal happens or doesn't and if
Kendall out like you know like
uh uh uh uh like out Maneuvers out
Maneuvers and becomes gets all the power
and is in charge or his plan implodes on
him and we watch him who I believe I
feel like he was if we had to name a
main character of this ensemble cast it
was him Kendall yeah I think Kendall's
the main character he's one on the call
sheet I would imagine yeah and uh I I
mean there's two ways to go because the
whole show if you think about it right
none of them I I thought of this last
when I watched it last night not a
single one of them did you ever see a
redeeming quality in one minute of this
show in in all four seasons I mean they
didn't even write in anything redeemed
and that's on purpose right not one of
them have ever I mean maybe with each
other they comforted each other but you
know that was all it's it's all surface
level and they'd slit each other's
throats immediately they've never ever
done a single
thing that wasn't disgusting and
self-serving and greedy right they are
not Opera and also they were raised
they're so dysfunctional they don't
operate that way but the whole show we
latched on to it but we're watching
these people that are [__] evil
people they're evil people they're being
evil I mean the thing that he did where
he called the election
is insane right it's starting riots on
here right and he knows he did something
morally corrupt in the in the highest
and he did it for him for his own
self-serving purpose to get to get a
deal and now shiv is doing it again and
we know what uh would would uh who's the
guy who the main guy uh what's his
father's name Logan Royce Logan Roy you
should do this all the time what he was
about and you see what a piece of [__]
Roman is and it's just like
in the end if Kendall succeeds it's
basically saying what else did you think
would happen like we've been showing you
that this is this world and this is the
who they are and it was already like
this with Logan so you you almost it
makes a statement right in your head you
don't as a viewer you don't there's no
protagonist no it's wild there's no
protagonist I think what they're trying
to protagonist maybe is
just the world
versus them I think what they're trying
to show is like this is real life this
is what the top one percent I think
they're trying to make a show about what
corporate greed really looks like and
how it directly impacts your life and
you don't even realize it so then I
believe that there is a chance that
Kendall succeeds but to tell you the
truth even if shiv succeeds or whoever
it works out it doesn't matter because
one of them is beating out the others
and it's all based on deception and
greed and so so there is no positive
here right right unless they unless for
some reason the whole family loses their
shirts right but I feel like the most
satisfying ending for a viewer
would be to see everything blow up in
Kendall's space because the way that
they are poisoning him in these last few
episodes because there was a time where
he like was so suicidal that you had
empathy yeah and then he he kicked that
stuff and then you saw him like possibly
want to change sometimes right and the
way that his Dynamic was with his
siblings kind of changed a little and
you're like okay are they trying
to show another side of him but then it
was all for not yeah because you know
what it's one of those things where it's
like one of the only shows that I've
been invested in for this long where
like you're almost certain like nobody's
gonna die like like you know what I mean
like it's not like they have the father
dive natural causes almost like it's not
it's not about that at all so it's like
you know nobody's dying It's the Go the
goal from episode one has been this the
last the last episode is basically going
to you know they're all chasing this you
know they succeed the father and who's
gonna who's gonna be crowned you know
what I mean but I think from a
satisfactory standpoint the way that
I've been feeling inside about the way
Kendall has been acting like he's you
see him almost like
like washed over in greed and power like
it's like it feels disgusting even when
he just in last episode said to shiv
like when he found out he was being lied
to he's like you called it like you
dirty piece of [__] like even though
he's talking to a girl who just told him
she's pregnant it's like you're you're
seeing like the unraveling where he's
like I will literally do anything to win
right now I'll I'll even cut your throat
knowing that you're pregnant started
right after he died the father right
he's like he they they they they started
deceiving everyone immediately and then
he told what's his name he's like this
is my plan to take over the world you're
the most powerful man in the world right
do you lose track sometimes like I found
myself the last couple of episodes
losing track of even what's going on
like the deal with the with the
Norwegian and all that I'm like why do
they want one person to win versus the
other like I don't understand what's
happening after before two episodes ago
I was like I get it I I like was like I
went through it in my head and I'm like
this is this and this is this is why
this the last two episodes have gotten
convoluted in a way that I was like what
why do they want the Democrat candidate
versus the Republican candidate yeah but
why is it serving him better if they
don't or do yeah I'm lost and then even
like but they did do something they did
show something that again could be
inside secret to the meter it could just
be because we already know that this
happens or we think that this happens
but when they have Matson release his
fudge numbers in the midst of
Presidential news chaos because it gets
lost in the news cycle so that must be
like a real thing that actually happens
like us as a society is like they do
that on purpose right right you know
yeah like yeah man I don't know but I'm
what do you think
I think that I think that well there the
the last scene will be the four of them
sitting at a diner and then the screen
goes black
no you know what I think I think that
just as like a as about them all going
to jail like the Seinfeld episode that's
what I think that they're all
Something's Gonna crumbling down and
who's gonna walk in and take the reins
Greg I think Greg they give it to Greg
as like a last minute I think the people
who would go down will be Roman and
Kendall right because shiv
shiv genuinely didn't want to make that
call no when they because that's that's
because what is the thing that could
what is what is the thing that's got
them in legal trouble though well first
of all
um first of all lying about the election
when they didn't know
the the final number so you're saying in
that scene they when they called it for
the guy who eventually won that was them
they didn't know there was not counted
the media swung that swung it but
they're still but right they thought
they were gonna start momentum in a way
that couldn't be
reversed and that if there was
controversy whoever was Voting it's
gonna be like I lost anyway yeah well
they just thought I think with the
wheels in motion and naming him it then
we all get set on that course and if the
due diligence is done they were hoping
that well he's gonna win we know he's
going to win because our polls are
saying he's going to win so let's just
call it we'll deal with the Fallout but
eventually it'll be proven that he was
going to win and maybe which is illegal
magic I mean you can't do Insane but
then also if you're what do you think
media companies do that you think that's
happened before in history for sure I
gotta think wow and then the other thing
he did was if you remember because he
wanted to he wanted to inflate the value
of the company at first in order to get
more value from Matson and then he
wanted to inflate it even further
because he wanted to not go with Matson
so he made up all those numbers as well
just like Matson was hiding that he
didn't have numbers if you remember that
yeah hiding the subscribers he's a life
plus presentation yeah and he inflated
everything all the polling all the
numbers all that they're valued at
because he wanted to get the the the the
shareholders to get more value be right
before this happened because it benefits
him to have more value right so he lied
about all that too it's just completely
illegal right you think they're going to
go to jail TV jail I mean no I mean not
as the actors in real life I mean it
depends on what they're trying to say if
the story because if they don't go to
jail it's like oh [__] that's kind of
sobering and sucky well if they don't go
to jail I think that would be because
that would be what most people think
happens to them in real life anyway so
it's either like it's either like you
know life sucks and you get [__]
ripped off and then you die and you know
and one of them takes over and the other
one gets [__] but it's still
devious or it's like maybe does does the
do they all get does a reckoning come
for all of them and for some reason or
another they get in legal trouble I
don't think that's happening in one
episode legal trouble but something's
gonna happen crazy something's gonna
happen crazy next week yeah but I won't
be watching it I'll be watching
Impractical Jokers on True TV thank you
so much
NCBS CBS CBS and if you're gonna go
watch the succession finale why don't
you do with the Deaton Watson hot dog
that's the only thing or kabasi yeah
I'll tell you one thing about them
no artificial flavors or fillers and
uncured Meats made the finest Meats
that's unbelievable these dogs talk to
me about it in Nashville at the Grand
Ole Opry on July 27 tickets are on sale
right now
I am actually going back on tour yes I
started in August wow every other
weekend through the end of the year get
them right back out there in Harford and
Syracuse and [__] uh
Connecticut I said that already yeah I'm
going all over the place dude I don't
know I'm going all over we're gonna do
it all I'm going to the places that I
haven't been like Appleton and
Springville just makes me hungry and
like Rockford and Peoria and you know
all these little places that I haven't
done I live in isn't it from Wayne's
World oh Aurora no no is it Peoria I
think they're in because I live in
Aurora Illinois
is where they're bit in their basement
in Peoria Peoria Peoria I believe all
right anyway what can you do we'll all
be announced soon all right I by the way
how many times have you urinated today
um I feel like I when I woke up I peed
I've I'm not kidding I've been counting
because I have to go again this
urination that I'm about to go take is
my 15th urination of the day so one of
two things you're either well hydrated
which is excellent or I think if you
don't pee a lot which I I have a problem
with that or you pee a lot that could be
a problem with your process I think I'm
overpaying but what I I am drinking I'll
tell you what I've drank today already I
woke up I drink two full glasses of
water then a coffee then did the workout
then did a full bottle of Essentia water
then I have now I've been using lmnt
salt like uh like a salt magnesium thing
I put salt in water drink that just had
another iced coffee and then I had a
bottle of water on so you're gonna
constantly I don't have an SD I think
you're answering it right now it's been
hey babe
[Music]